[Inaudible].
Into London. Uh, we were,
we were just talking about who was cool and who's not cool.
Um, um, these people are very cool. Uh,
and then I thought about you because you took your private jet this morning
and you flew through the polar vortex and you landed on the airport
here in England,
and you took a helicopter to the studio and you come in here now.
And I think that's the coolest thing I've ever. I mean, that's.
[Inaudible] like the James Bond of philanthropy. Welcome. Welcome to the CTO.
Thank you.
Um, please tell me, Mr. Gates, what is, uh,
what is the giving pledge?
Um, there's a lot of wealth that's been created,
and the question is, uh, if you want to give that away, who can you learn from?
And so myself and Warren buffet, um,
had dinners with people who'd been very successful and talked about, you know,
why did they believe in philanthropy and what were they going to do?
And we decided to create a group that would get together regularly,
encourage people to collaborate, to do it when they're younger,
to do more. Uh,
and so this giving pledge now has 122, uh, billionaires.
Who've committed to give the majority of their money away and are now learning
from each other about a habit, how to do it the best possible way.
And that's what you're doing these days is how to give away your money in the
best possible way.
Well, our foundation is very focused on, uh,
the health of the poorest in the world.
So I'm learning a lot about diseases working with scientists. Uh,
the foundation works my, my full-time effort.
And, and, uh, this week, uh, the foundation, uh,
the bill and Melinda Gates foundation, uh, and, and the,
uh, the Gates letter, uh, or Gates letter.com,
which is a URL on that. Um, it's, what's really, it was released this week.
It's a lot of good news in it.
That's right. Uh, we're making more progress than people are aware of. Uh,
we've reduced the number of poor countries dramatically.
So the idea that they stay poor, that's, uh, a bad myth.
Uh, fact in the next 20 years, we'll be down to very, very few poor countries.
Uh, we've improved health a lot by having generous aid and actually that, uh,
by improving the health, ironically, you'd think if you saved kids lives, you'd,
you'd get more kids and you'd have population problems. In fact,
as you improve health, uh, families decide voluntarily to have less kids.
So actually health is how you make sure that we were going to hit a peak
population and not have the type of feeding and educating and
environmental problems we'd have if the population kept growing.
So all good news.
It's, it's quite, it's quite a prediction you have.
It's a very audacious prediction that,
that when you are eight years old yourself into 35, right,
35, then there will be almost no poor countries.
That's right.
And I think people aren't aware of that because you see headlines about all the
setbacks, but this gradual improvement where countries like Brazil,
Korea, Mexico, China, that were once very poor, you know,
in 1960, almost every country in the world was poor except for the West.
And now we've moved them up. So they're almost all middle income.
They don't need aid. The number of countries left that need aid is, uh,
you know, about 50 or 60. And what I'm saying is that we'll drop down.
There'll be less than 10 of those. Uh,
if we keep being generous and being smart about improving the health and
agriculture of these poor countries, so that, you know,
it's good news that I'm afraid the normal way people see headlines, they,
they might not be aware of it. They might, uh, think it's all true.
How often do people say, sorry, Mr. Gates, that's just not possible.
There's a lot of cynicism. Uh,
and in most people don't get to go to Africa as much as I
do and look at the numbers. Uh, they just see that some aid program,
2% of the money was spent corruptly. And, uh, you know,
that's played up the bad news of an epidemic or a dictator taking over.
Uh, and so things like, uh, polio eradication,
where in the next five years, we think we can end that disease for all time.
You.
All did it. You already did in India.
India. Yeah. It's gone three years now with no cases. So we just celebrated, uh,
that kind of certification. We've still got it in, um, uh,
five countries right now. So we've got work to do, but we're,
we're optimistic on that as well.
How should, how should we think about foreign aid?
Well,
eight generosity saves lives and it buys vaccines by
seeds for farmers. And so I'm always encouraging countries to be more generous.
In fact, three of the most generous in the world are Norway, Sweden,
and Denmark. So your, your viewers to observe it.
[Inaudible].
We can, we don't have to bother so much anymore.
Keep up the good work. You need to keep it going. Uh,
there's often people come along and say, no, no, uh,
or cynical about it, but it really is out there making a huge difference.
I wish everybody could go and see, uh, the impact it, there are.
After all, all the ways to be a philanthropist,
you could like give the museum, you see him a new wing or something.
Yeah. That's not my thing.
Uh.
You know, mothers want their children to live.
And the fact that we haven't taken the latest science and, uh,
put, created a malaria vaccine, you know, it's still, uh,
over 600,000 kids a year dying of malaria. Uh,
and you know, why hasn't science made that a priority? Well, philanthropy,
there's no market for it because it's poor people who can't, uh,
spend to buy it. And so either government or philanthropy has to step in,
you know,
creating new seeds that let African farmers who are a third as pro productive
as, uh, enrich countries today, moving that up. So their kids have nutrition.
They can raise the school fees they need. Um, that's a lot more fun,
you know, I don't know what I'm no expert on heart. Uh, and it's,
I'm not criticizing that that's for other people to work on.
But you talk about the barking myths. What,
what is the most irritating myth about you?
Well, I wouldn't say there's anything that's irritating.
People are very nice to me. Uh, I'd say that, uh,
you know, the myth might be that, um, uh,
the most generous philanthropist of all time,
which in a pure economic sense, you know, through my life,
I'll give away over a hundred billion.
But
[inaudible].
Somebody who chooses to live in Africa and work in a hospital or give money.
So they're giving up a vacation or something they need, you know,
I've not had to sacrifice, as you said, I have the plane, uh, you know,
when I want to get a hammer, I get a hammer. Uh,
and so I've not really sacrificed my time or
my, uh, you know,
economic wellbeing in the same way that a lots of unnamed amazing
people do. So they're, you know, the world's best philanthropists.
[Inaudible].
You walked into a store and you saw something that you wanted and you
thought, Oh, no, that's too expensive.
I have very expensive tastes. Uh, you know,
when I decided to buy a plane, that was pretty expensive.
That's my big splurge. Uh, but I couldn't be here without it. So.
I love that plan. You, you,
we were talking about lists say because he's on a lot of lists
among other lists, one of the most intelligent in world, uh,
and you're number one on the list that was, uh, that was made, um,
uh, publicly recently, uh, a list, uh,
of the most influential, most admired people in the world.
And your number one, would that count for your
[inaudible] count? Is it, is it like that at home, around your dinner table?
I'm not number one at home. [inaudible].
Well, people are nice to me, but I, you know, uh,
my wife, Belinda sh you know, she does the most with the kids. And, uh,
I think she'd, she'd rank pretty high.
What about your parents? Uh, your father is still working with you.
Uh, how important is, is he in your life? Your mother is, she has passed.
Yeah. My mom, uh, passed away about 20 years ago. Uh,
my dad was a lawyer, uh, and then after he retired,
he volunteered to help me get the foundation going, uh,
and he's still involved, comes in, uh, and, uh,
he just turned 88. Uh, so he's, uh, you know,
still likes to work, uh, his hearing isn't at its peak.
Uh, but, uh, his, uh, integrity and example is, is still, uh,
extremely valuable.
Have you often, I mean, have you changed through the years as a,
as a person and, and, and I mean, doing this kind of work,
uh, because before there was a very different kind of work working with machines
and, and I mean, that's, that's a total different thing.
Have you changed as a person as well? I haven't been consulted.
Oh, certainly. Uh, Ben, you know, it's age, you mellow. Um,
in my twenties, I didn't believe in vacation. I didn't believe in weekends. Uh,
and you know,
I thought people who took Saturday and Sunday off were kind of wimpy and, uh,
uh, and,
and then I started taking weekends off and then I started taking vacations. And,
uh, you know, now I'm, I'm far more normal in that respect, you know, I,
I used to believe in, you know, staying all night at work, you know,
if possible two nights in a row that was kind of a cool macho thing. Now,
I'm not, not, I'm not good at that. Uh,
I won't make good decisions if I don't don't get some sleep. So yeah,
both in terms of, uh, how you work with people in teams,
um, how you empower them, you know, hopefully you get better as you get older.
Now, your, your pure genius, your cleverness may not may peak in its twenties.
I don't know. It's hard to measure these things. Uh,
so you should give up a little bit of that. You get, uh,
something where you can help others, uh, in their young years,
do their very best work.
You are known as a very competitive person. Uh, um, and, uh,
I must, I must ask you back in the days, was the Apple,
Apple boss, Steve jobs was here,
favorites opponent.
Well, he and I, in a weird sense, kind of grew up together. Uh,
I did the software for the Apple two, which was their first product. Um,
Microsoft did most of the software for the original Macintosh.
So we actually have more people working on that than Apple did.
So that was kind of a, a joint, uh, success.
Then Steve left Apple, uh,
did a company called next that I chose not to support cause I didn't think it
would sell very well. And it didn't. Uh, Dan,
when he came back to Apple,
we did a deal to support Apple and help it get going again.
And then he did such a phenomenal job that
the, his phones, his tablets started to dominate the industry.
And Apple actually became, uh, uh,
a bigger company even than Microsoft, which for us up until then, we'd been,
uh, more profitable. So did this mindblowing job.
And in that period were more competitors. We still saw each other.
And then as he got sick, I got, uh,
several chances to sit and talk to him at length about how lucky we'd been. And,
um, you know, he was a unique person and,
and in a lot of wonderful ways and in some pretty extreme ways. So, you know,
he, he pushed things even harder than I do. So, uh,
quite quite unique because.
You both had like quite a reputation and,
and P I don't know if people knew how close you were.
Well, they there's been some,
we did a thing together that Walt Mossberg had to sit and talk about how we'd
enjoyed our, our work together. Uh, that was about a year before Steve died.
And then the Walter Isaacson book talks about, uh, an afternoon.
I spent with Steve that was literally, uh,
just five weeks before he died.
We were discussing chess here with the, with the Magnus and also intelligence.
Uh, and that intelligence can be many things. Uh,
and you are obviously a very smart person, but when are you not?
When I play chess with him.
I want to try it. Uh, well, w it's a predetermined outcome, uh.
Because we, we, we know it might be, uh, but,
but you should know that he played with, uh, Zuckerberg,
uh, last week and it didn't go well for him either.
So he shouldn't be too nervous. [inaudible].
It was over 2100 players to players about 1600. It goes pretty quickly.
Yes, this is this. This must be, if we, because we have a table here,
so is it if it's okay by you? Is it okay by you sure.
Describe how will be it's it's speed. Chess, right?
I'll have 30 seconds. Uh, you can have as much time as you want.
And then, uh, then we'll see how it goes, punching a clock or not.
We haven't gotten to the clock, have the board MPS.
Oh, this is exciting.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible], I'm actually fairly good at goals. Board game.
Did you know before you started,
did you know that you were partly to thank for his success? Actually,
I didn't know that. I'm glad to hear it as a sponsor in the beginning. Super
[inaudible] The game, his home.
Oops.
Oh, that was quick. Oh, that was bad.
[Inaudible].
I usually last longer, I think
on this particular occasion,
I had to violate one of my main principles that I never
played for cheap tricks. And in this case,
this case I did, if,
if he had played rookie one here,
instead of giving an air hole for the queen now for the King, I would,
I would have had a losing position. So whatever, I wouldn't understand
[inaudible] I will say thank you very much for taking the time to be here with
us tonight. Uh,
it's it's been a joy to have you on the show and good luck with your
work you're on your way to devils.
What's going to happen there.
Uh, just a bunch of meetings, hopefully, uh, I'll spread the good news in my,
uh, uh, annual letter and get people committed to more,
more help for poor countries.
No party, uh.
Not for me, but it, uh, maybe for other people.
Do you never party?
You know, I, I sit and talk to people, but most animals,
I talk about malaria and tuberculosis for people who liked that.
I am a fun guy.
Thank you very much. Yeah. Thank you.
[inaudible] good luck with the Gates letter, the.com uh, the market,
and let's do it again.